From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi sitting in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Bim Adewunmi，替Ira Glass主持节目。
Do you know what the square footage of your home is?
你知道你家房子的面积是多少平方英尺吗？
Oh, God, Bim! How could you ask me that, you monster?
噢，天哪，Bim！你怎么能问我那个问题，你这个怪物？
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
That's my friend Mona. Mona bought a house after saving for 10 years. And she has a lot of complicated feelings about that house. For the majority of her life, she's thought of herself as a person who doesn't have money. That's what makes her, her-- no matter the actual reality. It's been that way since she was a kid.
那是我的朋友Mona。Mona攒了10年钱才买了一栋房子。对于那栋房子，她有着许多复杂的情绪。在她大半辈子的人生中，她一直认为自己是个没钱的人。这就是她的本质——无论现实情况如何。从她小时候起就是这样。
I went to a school, and just up the street was another school that was a private school, that was called Bancroft's. And we all used to call it Wankroft's because I think there was just this understanding that those rich kids were not like us. And they weren't like us because I think, even when you're like 11 years old, you know that the future ahead of them is just smoother. It just has less friction in it. And I think we resented them, even then, for that. Fun fact-- we went to an all-girls school and they called us the Virgin Megastore, which was also pretty accurate, I would say.
我上过一所学校，就在那条街的上方，还有另一所私立学校，叫班克罗夫特（Bancroft's）。我们以前都管它叫“那个阔佬学校”（Wankroft's），因为我觉得当时大家都有种共识，就是那些有钱人家的孩子和我们不一样。他们之所以和我们不一样，是因为我觉得，哪怕在你11岁的时候，你也能感觉到他们未来的路要平坦得多。他们的生活中障碍更少。我觉得那时候我们甚至因此而怨恨他们。顺便提一下，我们上的是一所女子学校，他们管我们叫“处女超级卖场”（Virgin Megastore），我觉得这名字起得还挺准的。
The Virgin Megastore?
“处女超级卖场”？
Yeah.
对。
Wow.
哇。
So accurate.
太准确了。
Children are so witty and horrible.
小孩子真是既机灵又可怕。
I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。
Mona knows the price of everything in her house. She can't forget-- the rugs from IKEA, the lamp she bought on sale, but still thinks was too expensive. Being able to afford a down payment, and now a mortgage, it just doesn't match how Mona has always seen herself or how she wants other people to see her.
Mona记得她家每样东西的价格。她无法忘记——来自宜家的地毯，打折买的台灯，但她还是觉得太贵了。能支付得起首付，现在还要还房贷，这与Mona一直以来对自己的看法或她希望别人看她的方式不符。
A few months after she moved in, she hosted a casual bachelorette party at the house for her childhood friend. The bridal party were all school friends she hadn't seen in ages. And Mona was feeling a little uncomfortable.
搬进去几个月后，她在家为一位儿时好友举办了一个随意的单身派对。参加派对的都是她很久没见的中学朋友。Mona感觉有点不自在。
Like, I'm really obsessed with cleanliness, normally. And I kind of deliberately didn't tidy or clean for the few days before they came, which is so weird, just because I didn't want it to look too nice.
比如，我通常真的有严重的洁癖。但她们来之前的那几天，我特意没有收拾或打扫，这真的很奇怪，只是因为我不想让家里看起来太好。
So you were trying to look kind of like shabby chic?
所以你是想走那种“破烂风”吗？
Not shabby chic, just shabby.
不是破烂风，就是单纯的破烂。
She didn't clean or dust the mirrors, didn't zhuzh up the cushions, didn't even vacuum for a couple of days beforehand. But despite that, to her horror--
她没有擦镜子或除尘，没有整理靠垫，甚至连吸尘都没有做。但尽管如此，让她感到惊恐的是——
The first friend to arrive, like, did this funny little sort of dance in my kitchen where she was like, oh my God, it's just so big. They asked if they could have a tour of the house. And I kind of was just like, yeah, and then didn't do anything about it. But then, the third time they asked-- they know all of my evasion tactics at this point-- they were just like, Mona, give us the fucking tour. So then I did. And I don't know. They were just like, it's nice. And I was like, thanks. And it shouldn't be a big deal, but it is, because I think it's-- I just don't think I deserve it, I guess.
第一个到达的朋友，在我的厨房里跳了那种滑稽的小舞，她当时说，天哪，这房子太大了。她们问能不能参观一下房子。我当时就像是，哦，好的，然后什么也没做。但后来，当她们第三次提出要求时——她们当时已经摸清了我所有的逃避策略——她们直接说，Mona，给我们参观一下。于是我就带她们看了。我不知道怎么说。她们只是说，这房子真好。我就说，谢谢。这本不该是什么大不了的事，但确实是，因为我觉得……我觉得我配不上它，我想。
These friends all knew how she'd grown up. Her parents had bought their house off an older lady and never updated it. So the carpets were old. The wallpaper was peeling in places. And there was a bit too much furniture. When friends would come over, Mona felt super aware of it and embarrassed, a weirdly identical emotion to what she was feeling in this new house now. The whole tour, she could feel them looking, which is the point of a house tour. And when they got upstairs in her bedroom, the closet door was ajar.
这些朋友都知道她成长环境如何。她的父母从一位老妇人手里买下了房子后从未翻修过。所以地毯很旧，墙纸在某些地方已经剥落。家具也实在太多了。当朋友来访时，Mona总是感到非常在意并为此感到尴尬，这和她现在在新房子里感受到的情绪奇怪地一致。在整个参观过程中，她能感觉到她们在打量，这就是房屋参观的目的。当她们上楼到她卧室时，衣柜门开着一条缝。
Oh, God. It's just so embarrassing to say these things out loud. In my closet, was a Gucci bag containing a Gucci handbag. Now I did not purchase said Gucci handbag. It was given to me, which is also incredibly bizarre.
噢，天哪。大声说出这些事太尴尬了。在我的衣柜里，有一个装有名牌手提包的Gucci包。我没有买那个Gucci包。它是别人送给我的，这也极其荒谬。
It was a work gift.
那是工作礼品。
And I just kind of saw an eye track on that. And that felt weird to me. And then, also in any human interaction, there's always this choice, right? Do you acknowledge the thing or do you not acknowledge a thing and just keep the conversation going? And I just know myself that if I would have acknowledged it, I would have made things even weirder by, like, overexplaining how I came to have this free Gucci handbag and why I haven't opened it since I got it.
我当时就注意到大家目光停留在了那里。这让我感觉很奇怪。而且在任何人类互动中，总是有这种选择，对吧？你是承认这件事，还是不予理会继续谈话？我了解我自己，如果我承认了，我会通过过度解释我如何得到这个免费的Gucci包以及为什么我从拿到它起就没打开过，从而把事情弄得更尴尬。
Why haven't you opened it?
你为什么没打开它？
Because, again, it doesn't feel like it belongs to me, even though I own it. Who I am is not somebody who owns a Gucci handbag. And therefore, it stays in the cupboard.
因为，还是那句话，它感觉不属于我，即使它是我名下的。我不是那种拥有Gucci包的人。因此，它一直待在柜子里。
To her, the designer bag is not actually a bag. It's a material asset, something she could sell if ever things got rough, because Mona is a person who knows that the ground can give way under your feet at any time.
对她来说，这个名牌包实际上不是包。它是一项物质资产，如果情况变糟了，她可以卖掉它，因为Mona是一个深知生活随时可能让你跌入谷底的人。
I have to point something out, though. Like--
不过，我必须指出一点。比如——
Uh oh.
哦豁。
No, no. I'm just-- I'm just kind of thinking, like, it's a weird thing to be like, "Oh, I don't know what to do. I have money." It's kind of like, "My diamond shoes, they're so tight."
不，不。我只是……我只是在想，那种“哦，我不知道该怎么办，我有钱”的态度是很奇怪的。这有点像是，“我的钻石鞋太挤脚了”。
Oh, I know. It's absolutely disgusting. I'm not expecting anyone that's listening to have any sympathy for this. To be really, really clear, this isn't framed as poor me. I feel so uncomfortable talking about this because, again, especially growing up, any time that someone with more resources than me complained-- yeah, I was just like, shut the fuck up. Like, I don't really want to hear it.
噢，我知道。这绝对令人作呕。我不指望任何听众会对此产生同情。说清楚，这不是为了卖惨。我谈论这些感到非常不舒服，因为还是那句话，尤其是在成长过程中，每当那些资源比我多的人抱怨时——是的，我的反应就是，闭上你的臭嘴。我真的不想听。
I'm not complaining. I'm really just trying to describe a feeling, I think. And actually, it still feels weird. The strangest feeling is the feeling of coming back, is the feeling of putting a key through the door and opening the door. And it's kind of like-- what's that thing-- agoraphobia, where you're scared of open spaces.
我不是在抱怨。我真的只是想描述一种感觉。而且，实际上，这仍然感觉很奇怪。最奇怪的感觉是回来的感觉，是用钥匙开门进屋的感觉。这有点像——那词叫什么来着——广场恐惧症，就是害怕开阔空间。
It's like really fucking weird to have that when you walk into your home, to have a fear of the open space. But if I'm walking upstairs to go to bed or something, no, it's really weird. I feel like a lodger here. It's transitory.
当你走进自己的家，对那种开阔空间产生恐惧，这真的太该死地奇怪了。但如果我正走上楼去睡觉之类的时候，不，这真的很怪。我觉得我像个寄宿者。这是暂时的。
So when you're in your house, and you're going up to bed, does it feel like an out-of-body sort of "it's me, but it's not really me"?
所以当你待在家里，正要上楼睡觉时，那种感觉是不是一种灵魂出窍般的“那是我，但又不是真的我”？
Exactly. I can see a woman going up the stairs. And every now and then, I remind myself that that person is me.
完全是。我能看到一个女人走上楼梯。每隔一段时间，我就会提醒自己，那个人是我。
For Mona, there was another big change, and it came a few months after she'd bought the house that had made her feel so unlike herself. She was on a long-awaited vacation with friends.
对Mona来说，还有另一个巨大的变化，发生在她买下那栋让她感到如此不像自己的房子几个月后。她当时正和朋友们进行一次期待已久的度假。
On the second-to-last night, got a phone call from my sister telling me that my mom-- I got a phone call from my sister telling my that my mom had had a stroke. So I came back immediately. And then she had another stroke. And yeah, she just-- she needs 24-hour care. And so she moved in with me. And I tried to do that as best I could.
在倒数第二个晚上，接到我姐姐打来的电话，告诉我我妈妈——接到我姐姐打来的电话，告诉我我妈妈中风了。所以我立即赶了回来。然后她又中风了一次。是的，她就是……她需要24小时照料。所以她搬来和我一起住。我尽我所能去做这件事。
Mona swung into action. She worked out the likely cost of care and for how long they could afford it. That money that she'd been so careful to save was actually being useful. At one point, she thought she might have to sell the house. And the weird thing was, it felt horribly familiar to be in a position where things felt more precarious again.
Mona立即采取了行动。她计算了大概的护理费用以及她们能负担多久。她曾经小心翼翼攒下的那笔钱，终于派上了用场。有那么一刻，她以为自己可能不得不卖掉这栋房子。奇怪的是，再次处于这种生活岌岌可危的状态，感觉竟如此令人毛骨悚然地熟悉。
When I moved into the house, and everything was OK for those six months, I didn't feel like me. And now, I do feel like myself because the fear is back. It's me just living in a nice house for now. This house isn't mine, really.
当我搬进这房子，前六个月一切顺利时，我不觉得那是真正的我。而现在，我感觉到了真正的自己，因为那种恐惧又回来了。我只是暂时住在好房子里。这房子其实不属于我。
On some level in my mind, the house isn't mine. And so that makes me feel like me, by dissociating slightly. When I did get more safe, I felt less like myself. I felt really disconnected with myself. I think actually being afraid is part of my identity.
在我内心深处的某个层面，房子不属于我。这让我通过轻微的离解感，感觉到真正的自己。当我变得更安全时，我反而觉得自己不像自己。我觉得自己与自我非常疏离。我实际上认为恐惧是我身份的一部分。
That's what our show today is all about. When something you understand to be such a fundamental part of yourself changes dramatically or goes away, and you're left wondering, is this still me, am I still who I think I am? That feeling of me minus me. We hear three people facing down monumental changes, wondering exactly that. Stay with us.
这就是我们今天节目的主题。当你认为构成你根本部分的东西发生了剧烈变化或消失时，你会不禁怀疑，这还是我吗？我还觉得自己是原来的我吗？那种“我失去了自我”的感觉。我们将听到三个人直面巨大的变化，思考着同样的问题。请继续收听。
Act 1, Voice Over. Sometimes you can plot the life of a singer from their discography. Think of the shift Beyoncé made from girl-group power pop to soul-baring global superstar. So I want to play you some recordings of Sandy Allen, who this first story is about, singing from four different points in his life. They map out the story of a person losing a big part of themself and building something to replace it. Here's the first recording. I'll call it the First Voice.
第一幕，旁白。有时你可以通过歌手的唱片目录来梳理他们的人生。想想碧昂丝从女子组合流行力量向灵魂乐全球巨星的转变。所以我想让你听听Sandy Allen的录音，也就是这个故事的主角，他人生中四个不同阶段的演唱。这些录音描绘了一个人失去了一部分重要的自我并构建替代品的故事。这是第一段录音。我称之为“第一种声音”。
OK, here's the first part of a very complicated new vocalese.
好的，这是一段非常复杂的新音节练习的第一部分。
(SINGING) Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah. Ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah-ah, ah. Good.
（歌唱）啊，啊，啊，啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊。啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊-啊，啊。好。
That was Sandy around the age of 14, singing scales in a voice lesson. Sandy was born with A Voice. By the age of four or five, he'd be hoisted onto the nearest table at family weddings to belt out "Somewhere Over The Rainbow." Those impromptu wedding gigs became roles in musicals at school and performing in choirs and choruses both at home and internationally. By the age of 15, Sandy had sung in a choir that performed at a San Francisco Giants game and also at the Sydney Opera House. He was good, and he knew it.
那是Sandy大约14岁时在声乐课上练习音阶。Sandy天生拥有一副好嗓子。四五岁时，他就会在家庭婚礼上被抱到桌子上大声唱《飞越彩虹》。那些临时的婚礼表演后来变成了学校音乐剧中的角色，并在国内外的唱诗班和合唱团中演出。15岁时，Sandy曾在旧金山巨人队的比赛中，以及在悉尼歌剧院的唱诗班演出过。他唱得很好，他自己也知道。
I was the person in the girls chorus who would sing the mega-mega high note, whether it was in "O Holy Night" or the end of the national anthem, while you're at the MLB game or whatever. I was that voice.
我是女子合唱团里那个负责唱超高音的人，无论是唱《圣善夜》还是唱美国国歌的结尾，当你身处大联盟比赛现场时。我就是那种声音。
Sandy's voice, with its three-octave range, was special enough to seriously consider Juilliard. Sandy could sound like a Disney princess. And in this parody of a song from The Little Mermaid, he really does.
Sandy的声音，拥有三个八度的音域，特别到足以让他认真考虑茱莉亚音乐学院。Sandy的声音听起来像个迪士尼公主。在这段戏仿《小美人鱼》歌曲的片段中，他确实唱出了那种味道。
(SINGING) Look at my face. Check out my chest. Wouldn't you say clamshell bras are the best? Looking around me, you'd think, sure, I could tap that. But as you know, I'm a merfolk, and so I'm a fish down below.
（歌唱）看着我的脸。看看我的胸。难道你不觉得贝壳内衣是最棒的吗？看看周围，你可能会想，当然，我可以拍那个。但如你所知，我是美人鱼，所以我下面是条鱼。
Sandy didn't go the Juilliard path. He became a writer instead. That's how I first got to know him, working in the same newsroom. But he still loved singing-- karaoke or just sitting at his piano with no audience, just the act of it. Sandy's voice-- high, vast in range, and also kind of effortless-- was programmed in, a cool part of the swirl of DNA that made Sandy Sandy.
Sandy没有走上茱莉亚音乐学院的路。他反而成了作家。我就是这样认识他的，在同一个新闻编辑部工作。但他依然热爱歌唱——卡拉OK，或者只是独自坐在钢琴前，没有观众，仅仅享受歌唱的行为。Sandy的声音——高亢、音域宽广且自然而然——是与生俱来的，是构成Sandy那独特DNA旋律中的酷炫部分。
Another thing about Sandy-- in his own words, he'd known he was different since he was a little kid, but he kept it to himself all through college and into his 20s, which was when he made his first trans friend. It was at that friend's house that Sandy first saw testosterone syringes. It would take another few years before Sandy came out as nonbinary and trans, which felt great to name out loud.
关于Sandy的另一件事——用他自己的话说，他从很小的时候就知道自己与众不同，但他直到大学和20多岁时都对此守口如瓶，那时他才结识了第一位跨性别朋友。正是在那个朋友家，Sandy第一次看到了睾酮注射针头。又过了几年，Sandy才公开自己的非二元性别和跨性别身份，大声说出来感觉真好。
Whenever he thought about actually starting testosterone himself, it came with a clutch of worries-- a severe anxiety around needles, he was nervous about his relationships with the people in his life. But when it came to articulating all those concerns--
每当他想到要真正开始使用睾酮时，总伴随着一堆担忧——对针头的极度焦虑，他担心自己与生活中人们的关系。但当谈到表达所有这些顾虑时——
The reason I would give myself was I can't give up my singing voice. Maybe I thought the universe would punish me, you know? Maybe I thought that, hey, if I do this "monstrous," quote, unquote, thing and start testosterone and ruin this beautiful voice that I spent so much of my childhood building, then the punishment I'll receive is that I won't ever feel the pleasure of singing again.
我给自己的理由是，我不能失去我的歌声。也许我以为宇宙会惩罚我，你知道吗？也许我以为，嘿，如果我做了这种所谓的“怪物”行为，开始使用睾酮并毁掉这副我花了整个童年建立起来的美妙嗓音，那么我受到的惩罚就是我再也无法享受歌唱的快乐了。
This fear of losing his voice-- it's one that many trans people have experienced and spoken about. Sandy's fear was that there would be a total absence of a singing voice. He didn't know any famous trans men singers, and he'd heard one trans guy talking on a podcast about how he couldn't sing anymore. Four years went by.
这种害怕失去嗓音的恐惧，许多跨性别者都经历过并谈论过。Sandy害怕的是歌唱声音的彻底消失。他不认识任何著名的跨性别男歌手，他也听过一个跨性别男生在播客里说他再也不能唱歌了。四年过去了。
OK, here's the second set of recordings. I'm calling this one "The Countdown Sessions."
好的，这是第二组录音。我称之为“倒计时环节”。
(SINGING) Somewhere over the rainbow.
（歌唱）飞越彩虹……
This is from late 2020, about 21 months ago. At this point, Sandy had made the choice to start T. But before he started, he felt compelled to sing some of his favorite songs and record himself doing it.
这是2020年底录的，大约21个月前。那时，Sandy已经决定开始使用睾酮。但在开始之前，他觉得有必要唱几首他最喜欢的歌，并录下自己演唱的过程。
What I ended up doing, when I look back at it now, was I was recording really nostalgic stuff for myself, stuff that I had sung in plays, songs that I had sung in my car as a teenager. One of the songs that I recorded on my old voice was "Somewhere Over The Rainbow." It was almost like I reversed all the way to the beginning. I think it was like-- it almost felt like a memorial, you know? Like, hey, let's give this one last spin, you know?
现在回想起来，我最终做的是录下那些对我来说非常怀旧的东西，我在戏里唱过的东西，我在青少年时期在车里唱过的歌。我用原本的声音录下的歌曲之一就是《飞越彩虹》。这几乎就像是我一路倒转回到了起点。我想那就像——感觉像是一场纪念，你知道吗？就像，嘿，最后再来唱一遍，你知道吗？
You said this thing when we spoke earlier that it felt like a countdown to never singing again.
我们早些时候交谈时你说过，那感觉就像是在为不再唱歌做倒计时。
Yeah, yeah. I was sad. I was-- I felt guilty. It was like, well, if I'm going to kill this sweet thing that's been my friend for all this time, I will at least enjoy our last days together.
是啊，是的。我很伤心。我……我感到内疚。就像是，好吧，如果我要杀死这件一直陪伴我这么久的甜美事物，至少我要享受我们在一起的最后时光。
(SINGING) Where troubles melt like lemon drops away above the chimney tops, that's where--
（歌唱）忧愁像柠檬糖一样融化在烟囱之上，那里是……
I was mourning an entire selfhood that was the one that I had created. I never felt like a woman, but I had to act like a woman for a very long time. And I was saying goodbye to all of that.
我在哀悼一个完整的自我，那个我曾经构建出来的自我。我从未觉得自己是个女人，但我被迫扮演女人很长一段时间。我是在和这一切告别。
Did it really feel like you would never sing again, like never, ever?
真的感觉你会再也唱不了歌了吗，就是永远、永远都不能了？
Well, I think that if I'm being honest, my sense was my new voice, whatever it was going to be, was going to be so bad that I just wouldn't want to.
嗯，我想如果我诚实地说，我的感觉是我的新声音，无论它会是什么样，都会变得那么糟糕，以至于我根本不想唱了。
[MUSIC - BILLIE EILISH, "MY FUTURE"]
[音乐 - 比莉·艾利什，《My Future》]
(SINGING) I can't seem to focus, and you don't seem to notice I'm not here. I'm just a mirror.
（歌唱）我似乎无法集中注意力，而你似乎没注意到我不在。我只是面镜子。
This is one of his newer favorites, Billie Eilish's "My Future." As good as he sounds--
这是他较新的最爱之一，比莉·艾利什的《My Future》。尽管他唱得很好——
I mostly hear how thin and kind of tentative that voice is and how much it doesn't fit me.
我大多听到的是那声音是多么单薄和迟疑，以及它有多么不适合我。
(SINGING) Can't you hear me? I'm not coming home.
（歌唱）你听不到我吗？我不会回家的。
You told me that the last song that you ever recorded using your voice pre-T was "Changes," which is very on the nose--
你告诉我，你用睾酮前嗓音录下的最后一首歌是《Changes》，这真是太贴切了——
Very on the nose.
太贴切了。
--as songs go. You know, just this idea of you flipping through the catalog and, ah-ha, "Changes," because of the changes I'm going through, see? But I love that so much. I love that that was where your brain and your voice landed. Can you play a little bit of that recording?
——正如歌名一样。你知道，只是你翻看目录时想到的点子，啊哈，《Changes》，因为我正在经历改变，看懂了吗？但我太喜欢这个了。我很高兴你的大脑和嗓音最终落脚在这一首。能放一小段那个录音吗？
Yeah.
好的。
[MUSIC - DAVID BOWIE, "CHANGES"]
[音乐 - 大卫·鲍伊，《Changes》]
(SINGING) I'm too fast to take that test. Ch-ch-ch-ch-changes. Turn to face the strange.
（歌唱）我太快无法通过那次测试。变、变、变、变化。转身面对陌生。
What do you think when you hear that version of yourself singing it?
当你听到那个版本的自己在唱这首歌时，你觉得怎么样？
I hear me singing a male artist with a kind of yearning, you know? Yeah, it sounds like the most excited of any of the takes, right? I hear more energy in my voice there.
我听到自己在唱一位男歌手的歌，带着一种渴望，你知道吗？是的，听起来像是所有录音中最兴奋的一段，对吧？我在那个声音里听到了更多的能量。
It's like he knows in his gut that this is what he would like to sound like, what he could sound like, and he's itching to get to a time when it's already happened.
就像他内心深知这就是他想要的声音，这才是他能发出的声音，他急切地想跨越到那个已经发生的时刻。
I was like, yeah, deep down, super excited for what was on the other side.
我当时的感觉是，是啊，内心深处，超级期待另一边的样子。
(SINGING) So I turn myself to face me, but I never caught a glimpse of how others must see the faker.
（歌唱）所以我转身面对自己，但我从未瞥见别人眼中的伪装者。
Let me play the third set of recordings. I'm calling it "Rough Going."
让我放第三组录音。我称之为“困难时期”。
(SINGING) I-- (CHANGING KEY) I--
（歌唱）我——（变调）我——
What the fuck key are we in?
我们到底是在什么调子上？
Sandy's voice in a new phase and not always successful at making the exact sounds he wanted it to be making.
Sandy的声音处于一个新的阶段，并不总是能发出他想要的那种精确声音。
(SINGING) I never dreamed that I'd meet somebody like you. I never dreamed that I'd lose somebody like you. No, I--
（歌唱）我从未梦想过会遇到像你这样的人。我从未梦想过会失去像你这样的人。不，我——
[BLOWS RASPBERRY]
[发出“噗”的一声]
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It took some time for the T to have a notable effect on Sandy's voice. Those recordings are from about two months after he'd started.
睾酮对Sandy的嗓音产生明显影响花了一些时间。这些录音是他开始注射大约两个月后录的。
I couldn't sing sounds that even sounded OK at all. I was like a screechy teen sound. I had full-on moments where-- that quintessential voice break, where you go to sing a note, and there's nothing there.
我根本唱不出听起来还行的声音。我就像个变声期尖叫的青少年。我完全有那种典型的嗓音断裂时刻，你想唱一个音符，结果什么都没有。
It's reminding me of-- it's different, but after top surgery, for example,
这让我想起——虽然不同，但在做完平胸手术后，
I was so weak in my upper body that I couldn't lift a glass. I couldn't open a door. And over that period of months of learning how to use my upper body again, I mean, it was like these small victories, like when I could hold a mug, and it didn't feel so heavy that I was going to drop it.
我的上半身太虚弱了，连杯子都拿不起来。我没法开门。在重新学习如何使用上半身的那些个月里，那是些小小的胜利，比如当我可以拿住一个马克杯，而不会觉得它重到会掉下来的时候。
In those croaky, newly post-T days, Sandy found himself attempting to sing the songs of artists that he wouldn't have approached before. He tried Leonard Cohen. He tried Johnny Cash. None of it was sounding quite right.
在那些刚开始注射睾酮、嗓音嘶哑的日子里，Sandy试图去唱一些他以前不会碰的歌手的歌。他试过莱昂纳德·科恩。他试过约翰尼·卡什。没一个是听起来对的。
Testosterone does a lot of things. It changes the way weight is distributed on your body, as well as the thickness of your skin and hair and even how fast your hair grows. It also thickens the vocal cords, making some voices break and deepen. And Sandy's voice was breaking.
睾酮会做很多事。它改变了身体的脂肪分布方式，以及皮肤和毛发的厚度，甚至改变了毛发的生长速度。它还会加厚声带，导致一些人的嗓音断裂和低沉。而Sandy的嗓音正在断裂。
Waiting for this fourth-decade second puberty to kick in was kind of surreal. Sandy had had top surgery, was growing facial hair. And now, he was waiting for his voice to drop. And then one day--
等待这四十岁前的第二次青春期发生真是太超现实了。Sandy做了平胸手术，长出了胡须。现在，他在等嗓音低沉下来。然后有一天——
I sat down at the piano, I hit a middle C, and I could not sing it.
我坐在钢琴前，弹了一个中音C，但我唱不出来。
Wow.
哇。
You know what I mean? It was gone. Middle C was gone. For context, middle C used to be where I would have started my scales, you know? It would have been kind of just like, it's the easiest thing to sing is a middle C on my previous voice. That was like, uh-oh.
你知道我的意思吗？它没了。中音C没了。背景说明一下，中音C曾经是我开始练习音阶的地方，你知道吗？在以前的嗓音里，唱中音C是最简单的事。那真是，呃哦。
It wasn't like a weaning off? It wasn't kind of like, oh, it's tapering, and now-- it was just like, oh, I can't do that?
这不是像逐渐减弱？不像那种，哦，它在变细，然后——它就是，哦，我做不到了？
Yeah. My voice was, like, gone. The voice that I had was honestly a few notes big. It was absurd. I sat there at the piano going, oh, no, there's almost nothing here. What song can I even make out of such a small ability?
是的。我的嗓音，怎么说，没了。我拥有的嗓音老实说也就几个音符大。太荒谬了。我坐在钢琴前，想着，噢不，这里几乎什么都没有。这么小的能力我能唱什么歌呢？
It was a very horrible thing to all of a sudden have my voice go from being the most familiar part of my body on some level to this completely unknown. I didn't even know what it could do, let alone how to make it do it. I remember the song where I sang it, and it was like, oh, my god, this sounds like a song.
嗓音突然从某种程度上身体最熟悉的部分变成了完全未知的东西，那真是太可怕了。我甚至不知道它能做什么，更不用说如何控制它了。我记得那首歌，我唱了出来，感觉就像，噢天哪，这听起来像首歌。
What was the song?
那是什么歌？
It was "Your Song" by Elton John, which is not a song that I like. And I remember having this moment of like--
是埃尔顿·约翰的《Your Song》，这不是我喜欢的歌。我记得当时有种感觉，像是——
[GASPS]
[倒吸一口气]
--oh, my god. It's a song. I could feel it. It was like the first time that I was able to kind of step back and cross my arms and just watch. It was like I was going, whoa, look at this thing go.
——噢天哪。这是一首歌。我能感觉到。那是我第一次能够退后一步，交叉双臂，静静观看。就像我当时在说，哇，看这玩意儿表现得多好。
Now I have a much better sense of where the voice starts, and where it can get to. I have a much better sense of how to actually use it. And I feel it when I'm doing it. It's a bigger instrument.
现在我对嗓音的起始位置以及它能达到什么程度有了更好的把握。我知道如何真正地去使用它。而且当我唱歌时，我是能感觉到它的。这是一种更大的乐器。
Bigger how?
更大是怎么体现的？
Hmm. I think when I say that in my mind, I'm picturing a violin and a cello. There's so many examples of instruments where there's a smaller version that's higher. There's a piccolo, and then there's a flute.
嗯，我想当我脑子里这么说的时候，我在构思一把小提琴和大提琴。有很多乐器的例子，有高音的小版本。有短笛，然后有长笛。
And it's like, I'm just rocking a new-- it's a bigger, and it's lower. In order to make a lower sound, you have to move more air through that thing. I need more in order to power it.
就好像，我只是在摆弄一种新的——它更大，也更低沉。为了发出更低的声音，你必须通过那个东西推动更多的空气。我需要更多的动力来驱动它。
We're on the last set of recordings now. Let's call these "Sandy's Third Voice."
现在我们来到最后一组录音。我们称之为“Sandy的第三种声音”。
[MUSIC - BILLIE EILISH, "MY FUTURE"]
[音乐 - 比莉·艾利什，《My Future》]
(SINGING) I can't seem to focus, and you don't seem to notice I'm not here. I'm just a mirror. You--
（歌唱）我似乎无法集中注意力，而你似乎没注意到我不在。我只是面镜子。你——
Sandy singing Billie Eilish again on his piano at home. We were on the phone, and I asked him to play me a couple of songs while we were talking in this third voice, the post-post-testosterone voice. It was the first time he'd sung in front of anyone beside his husband and a couple of friends. The squeaks and croaks have abated, but Sandy's voice is still in flux. The voice rehab is ongoing.
Sandy在家里对着钢琴再次演唱比莉·艾利什。我们通着电话，我让他一边跟我谈话一边用第三种声音，也就是注射睾酮后又过了一段时间的声音唱了几首歌。这是他除了丈夫和几个朋友之外，第一次在别人面前唱歌。嘶哑和破音已经减轻了，但Sandy的嗓音仍然处于波动中。嗓音康复还在继续。
(SINGING) Can't you hear me? I'm not coming home.
（歌唱）你听不到我吗？我不会回家的。
It's easy to hear the difference, even only a few months apart. The voice is obviously deeper. But more than that, it sounds strong, like he's been practicing.
很容易听出其中的区别，即便相隔只有几个月。声音明显变低了。但不仅如此，它听起来很有力量，就像他一直在练习一样。
(SINGING) I'll see you in a couple years.
（歌唱）几年后我会再见你的。
That sounds more lived in than what you sent me back in March.
那比你在三月份发给我的听起来更自然了。
Ha, good. [LAUGHS] Yeah, probably.
哈，太好了。[笑声]是的，可能吧。
Of course, I had to ask Sandy to sing "Changes," too.
当然，我不得不也让Sandy唱了《Changes》。
[MUSIC - DAVID BOWIE, "CHANGES"]
[音乐 - 大卫·鲍伊，《Changes》]
(SINGING) Turn to face the strange. Ch-Ch-Changes. Pretty soon now, you're going to get older. Time may change me, but I can't trace time. I said that time may change me, but I can't trace time.
（歌唱）转身面对陌生。变、变、变化。很快，你就会长大。时间可能会改变我，但我无法追踪时间。我说过时间可能会改变我，但我无法追踪时间。
Woo, ooh!
呜，噢！
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
How did that feel?
那感觉如何？
Oh. A little scary. [LAUGHS]
噢。有点吓人。[笑声]
How does your voice feel singing it today?
你今天唱的时候嗓音感觉如何？
OK. Yeah. Every day that I wake up and I can just sing is like another beautiful, glorious gift. It's like, wow, here we go. I can still do it.
还好。是的。我醒来能唱歌的每一天都像是一份美丽、光荣的礼物。就像是，哇，开始吧。我还做得到。
And some days are better. And some days are worse. But it's like, I'm no longer in this period of murk and everything feeling off and searching. I'm on the other side, and I'm just living my life.
有些日子更好。有些日子更糟。但就像，我不再处于那种昏暗不明、一切都感觉不对劲和探索中的时期。我在另一边，我只是在过我的生活。
His effortless three-octave first voice and his second unmaintained voice and the raw post-T voice, they're all the bones of this new voice that he had to build up himself.
他那自然而然的三个八度第一嗓音、未经维护的第二嗓音，以及注射睾酮后粗粝的嗓音，它们都是他必须亲手构建的这种新嗓音的基石。
It's a different sound. What I enjoy about it, in some sense, is it's a trans voice. I don't know if I sound like a cis guy. I think that I sound like something else, and I'm a product of a very specific right set of things that can happen to a body. And I love that too.
这是一种不同的声音。在某种意义上我喜欢它，因为它是一种跨性别者的声音。我不知道我听起来是否像顺性别男性。我觉得我听起来是另一种东西，我是身体能够发生的某种非常特定的正确组合的产物。我喜欢这一点。
I love that it winds up being a sound that isn't like others. It feels more grown up and a little more fragile, perhaps, because it's new. But also, I'm always pushing it. I'm always trying stuff that I haven't done before.
我喜欢它最终成为一种与其他声音不一样的声音。它感觉更成熟，也许更脆弱一点，因为它是新的。但我也总是在推动它。我总是在尝试我以前没做过的事情。
Something he'd never even thought to imagine before now was harmonizing with himself.
在此之前，他从未想过会和自己进行和声。
I had a moment the other day when we were playing some of my old voice over the stereo, and then I, in my voice now, sang along with it and did a self-duet. And there was just this moment of, like, whoa.
前几天我有过一刻，我们在立体声里播放我以前的嗓音，然后我，用现在的嗓音，跟着它一起唱，完成了一个自我对唱。那一刻感觉真的，哇。
[MUSIC - BILLIE EILISH, "MY FUTURE"]
[音乐 - 比莉·艾利什，《My Future》]
(SINGING) I'm not coming home. Do you understand?
（歌唱）我不会回家的。你听明白了吗？
And I think part of that is just the sheer uncanniness of, of course, it's the same voice. It's like, it is me, and you could hear how, in a sense, faithful a replica this is with a big difference. It felt kind of like I was breaking time, the kind of fossil of my old voice in the room and then my new one joining it, dueting with my former voice. Suddenly, my former voice becomes so much more interesting to me this way, where it's not just this thing that I walked away from.
我想部分原因仅仅是因为那种纯粹的不可思议感，当然，这是同一个嗓音。就好像，这是我，你可以听到在某种意义上，这是一种多么忠实的复制品，但又有巨大的不同。感觉就像是我打破了时间，旧嗓音的化石在房间里，然后新嗓音加入进来，与我以前的声音对唱。突然间，我以前的声音通过这种方式对我来说变得有趣多了，它不再仅仅是我所离开的东西。
(SINGING) Not with anybody else. Just wanna get to know myself.
（歌唱）不想和任何人在一起。只想去了解我自己。
Sandy had expected a split in himself with the arrival of a new voice, but what was once so unfamiliar is somehow now the truest expression of himself. You could even say he turned to face the strange.
Sandy曾预料到新声音的到来会让他产生分裂，但曾经感到如此陌生的东西，现在却成了他表达自我最真实的方式。你甚至可以说，他转身面对了陌生。
(SINGING) I know supposedly I'm lonely now. Lonely now. Know I'm supposed to be unhappy without someone. Without someone. But aren't I someone?
（歌唱）我知道我本该感到孤独。孤独。知道我本该在没有某人的情况下感到不快乐。没有某人。但我不就是某人吗？
Coming up, a mysterious man in a hospital parking lot offers to grant one wish. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，医院停车场里一个神秘男人提议满足一个愿望。几分钟后，芝加哥公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, in for Ira Glass. Today's show, Me Minus Me, stories of people who change a fundamental part of themselves and wonder if they're still who they thought they were.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Bim Adewunmi，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目是“我失去了自我”，讲述那些改变了自身根本部分并怀疑自己是否还是原来的那个人的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two, Me Minus You. I reached out to one of my favorite writers, Marie Phillips, and told her about today's theme. Two days later, she'd written this short story and sent it to me. Here's Marie.
我们来到了第二幕，我失去了你。我联系了我最喜欢的作家之一Marie Phillips，告诉了她今天的主题。两天后，她写好了这个短篇故事并发给了我。有请Marie。
Stephanie sat with her parents by her sister's bed. Her mother was reading aloud from The Road Less Traveled while her father muttered to himself as he did the crossword. Fluorescent lights buzzed, machines hummed and beeped, and the sneakers of hurrying nurses squeaked on rubber floors.
Stephanie坐在她父母身边，守在妹妹的病床旁。她母亲在朗读《少有人走的路》，她父亲则一边自言自语一边做填字游戏。荧光灯发出嗡嗡声，机器不断鸣响和滴答，护士们匆忙奔走的球鞋在橡胶地板上发出吱吱声。
Stephanie tried to ignore it all as she flicked through client emails on her phone, but it was impossible. Even if she could screen out the noise, there was the cloying smell of patchouli oil, Rachel's favorite, from the diffuser by the bed. Stephanie hadn't thought that there could be a worse smell than the hospital's mix of disinfectant, disease, and cheap canned soup, but patchouli oil was it.
Stephanie试图忽略这一切，她用手机刷着客户邮件，但这根本不可能。即使她能过滤掉噪音，空气中还有一种令人作呕的广藿香油味，那是Rachel的最爱，来自床边的扩香机。Stephanie没想到还有比医院那种混合了消毒水、疾病和廉价罐头汤更难闻的味道，但广藿香油就是其中之一。
Rachel had been in a coma for six months, some bug she'd picked up on one of her endless overseas trips to find herself. Nobody could figure out why she hadn't woken up yet, but the doctors encouraged them to keep visiting, keep talking to her, hoping that something would prompt her to open her eyes. Typical Rachel, thought Stephanie, attention seeking even while unconscious.
Rachel已经昏迷六个月了，那是她在一次无休止的寻找自我的海外旅行中染上的某种病菌。没人弄明白她为什么还没醒来，但医生鼓励他们继续探望，继续和她说话，希望某种东西能促使她睁开眼睛。典型的Rachel，Stephanie心想，连失去知觉的时候都在博取关注。
Stephanie's mother finished her chapter and pressed play on an ancient portable tape deck. The sound of flutes and whale song filled the air. I'm going to stretch my legs, said Stephanie.
Stephanie的母亲读完了章节，按下了老式便携录音机上的播放键。长笛和鲸鱼之歌的声音充斥了整个空间。我去伸展一下腿，Stephanie说。
There was a coffee cart by the front door of the building. Stephanie ordered a double espresso and briefly considered, then rejected, a sweaty pastry. The coffee tasted like tarmac. She took it outside into the car park and lit a cigarette.
大楼的前门旁有个咖啡车。Stephanie点了一杯双份浓缩咖啡，短暂考虑后又拒绝了一块油腻的点心。咖啡尝起来像沥青。她把它带到室外停车场，点燃了一支烟。
A man shuffled over. He was short and dressed in a long trench coat with a collar turned up and a battered black hat pulled down over his brow, like a PI in an old detective series, except that his skin was green-- not nauseous green, but actual green, traffic light green. "Hello, Rachel," he said.
一个男人走了过来。他个子不高，穿着一件长风衣，领子立着，一顶破旧的黑帽子压得很低盖住眉毛，就像老派侦探剧里的私家侦探，除了他的皮肤是绿色的——不是那种恶心的绿色，而是真正的绿色，红绿灯那种绿色。“你好，Rachel，”他说。
Stephanie started, then shook her head. "My name's not Rachel," she said. She moved her handbag closer to her body. "My apologies," said the green man. "You are Stephanie, and your sister in the coma is Rachel. Allow me to introduce myself. I am the genie of the lamp." He bowed.
Stephanie吓了一跳，然后摇了摇头。“我叫Stephanie，”她说。她把手提包往身边拉了拉。“抱歉，”绿男人说。“你是Stephanie，你那个昏迷的妹妹是Rachel。允许我自我介绍一下。我是神灯精灵。”他鞠了一躬。
Stephanie rolled her eyes. Friend of Rachel's, obviously. Only Rachel would have friends who paint themselves green and call themselves genies. She turned to go, but the green man grabbed her by the wrist.
Stephanie翻了个白眼。显然是Rachel的朋友。只有Rachel才会交那种把自己涂成绿色并自称精灵的朋友。她转身要走，但绿男人抓住了她的手腕。
"I have something to show you," he said. He put his other hand on her forehead. She felt herself become dizzy, then her mind filled with images playing out like a film. She saw Rachel unpacking her backpack in her filthy flat, dirty clothes and half-read self-help books and ashtrays overflowing with Rachel's foul menthol cigarettes.
“我有东西要给你看，”他说。他把另一只手放在她的额头上。她感到一阵眩晕，然后大脑中充斥着像电影画面一样的影像。她看到Rachel在肮脏的公寓里打开背包，脏衣服和看了一半的励志书，以及满是Rachel那难闻的薄荷烟头的烟灰缸。
She saw the antique lamp at the bottom of the bag wrapped in an old T-shirt. She saw Rachel rubbing at a tarnish on it and the green man appearing, him offering her three wishes, as is traditional. Money, sex, power, thought Stephanie. What else is there?
她看到包底用旧T恤裹着的古董灯。她看到Rachel擦去上面的污渍，然后精灵出现了，向她提供三个愿望，按照传统。钱、性、权力，Stephanie心想。还能有什么别的？
But she saw Rachel looking at the mess around her. "I need to get my shit together," Rachel told the genie. "I need to be more like Stephanie. She's got it all-- husband, career, big house. First wish, I want to be like Stephanie."
但她看到Rachel环顾四周的混乱。“我得振作起来，”Rachel对精灵说。“我得变得更像Stephanie。她拥有一切——丈夫、事业、大房子。第一个愿望，我想变得像Stephanie。”
"Your wish is my command," said the genie. There was a flash, and Rachel collapsed to the ground. In that instance, Stephanie-- or someone who looked like Stephanie-- appeared in Rachel's apartment.
“如你所愿，”精灵说。一道闪光过后，Rachel倒在地上。那一瞬间，Stephanie——或者说长得像Stephanie的人——出现在Rachel的公寓里。
She was wearing a tailored cashmere suit and had her hair neatly curled in a bun. The Stephanie in Rachel's apartment walked over to a mirror and stood at it, mouth wide. Stephanie watched Stephanie watching Stephanie in the mirror.
她穿着剪裁得体的羊绒套装，头发整齐地盘成发髻。Rachel公寓里的那个Stephanie走到镜子前，张大了嘴。Stephanie看着Stephanie看着镜子里的Stephanie。
Mirror Stephanie ran her hands over her body. She started to laugh. She turned to the genie. "This is not what I meant, she said. I just wanted to know how she gets what she's got. But no, it's good. It's really good, but it's not enough. It's her body, but I'm still Rachel.
镜子里的Stephanie用手抚摸着身体。她开始大笑。她转向精灵。“这不是我的意思，”她说。“我只是想知道她是怎么得到她所拥有的一切的。但这挺好，这确实很好，但这还不够。这是她的身体，但我依然是Rachel。
OK, second wish. I want to actually be Stephanie. I want to forget I was ever me. Let me be her completely for six months and then come back and get me. Then I can use my third wish to go back into my own body, but I'll remember what it was like being her." "Your wish is my command," said the genie again.
好的，第二个愿望。我想真正变成Stephanie。我想忘记我曾经是我。让我完全成为她六个月，然后再回来找我。这样我就能用第三个愿望回到我自己的身体里，但我会记得当她是什么感觉。”“如你所愿，”精灵再次说道。
There was another flash. Then everything went dark. Stephanie felt the genie remove his hand from her forehead. She opened her eyes and found herself back in the hospital car park, her cigarette burned down to the filter.
又是一道闪光。然后一切陷入黑暗。Stephanie感觉到精灵把手从她额头上拿开。她睁开眼睛，发现自己回到了医院的停车场，手里的烟已经烧到了过滤嘴。
"I'm Rachel," she said. "I'm Rachel? Crystals, magic mushrooms, energetic healing, Women Who Run With The Wolves, exotic dancing, caftan Rachel? She hasn't even got a fucking pension!" The genie nodded. "But I don't understand. I feel like me. How can I be Rachel when I'm still me?"
“我是Rachel，”她说。“我是Rachel？水晶、魔法蘑菇、能量疗法、《与狼共舞》的女人、异国情调舞蹈，那个穿长袍的Rachel？她甚至连养老金都没有！”精灵点了点头。“但我还是不明白。我感觉像我自己。当我依然是我的时候，怎么可能是Rachel？”
"Think of Stephanie like a car," said the genie. "The machinery still operates in the same way, but it's Rachel behind the wheel, even if she's not aware of it. Let me give you an example. What are you smoking, Stephanie?"
“把Stephanie想象成一辆车，”精灵说。“机械装置运作方式没变，但开车的是Rachel，即使她自己没意识到。我给你举个例子。你在抽什么，Stephanie？”
Stephanie looked down at the cigarette in her hand. "Ugh," she said, "Menthol! I would never!" She tossed the revolting thing away. "It's a lot to take in," said the genie.
Stephanie低头看了看手里的烟。“呃，”她说，“薄荷味！我绝不可能抽这个！”她把那个恶心的东西扔了。 “这有点难以接受，”精灵说。
She took a steadying breath, wiping her hand on her skirt. "So if I'm Rachel, where's Stephanie?" "Asleep." "In there?" she said, pointing at the hospital, where Rachel's body lay. "Yes," said the genie. "And when you vacate this body, Stephanie will come back. She won't remember the last six months or any of this. But other than that, she'll carry on as normal."
她深吸一口气稳住情绪，擦了擦手上的裙子。“如果我是Rachel，那Stephanie在哪？”“睡着了。”“在那里面？”她指着医院，Rachel身体躺的地方。“是的，”精灵说。“当你离开这个身体，Stephanie会回来。她不会记得过去六个月或这一切。但除此之外，她会照常生活。”
"And I'll be Rachel again, fully Rachel, but I'll remember it all?" "That's right." She'd be Rachel in her crappy basement flat with her crappy job giving teenage girls piercings in Claire's Accessories and her crappy parade of crappy boyfriends who smelled like unwashed hair while Stephanie went back to her mansion and her law firm and her hot house-husband who cooks like a Michelin-starred chef?
“那我又会变成Rachel，完全的Rachel，但我会记得这一切？”“没错。”她会回到她那破地下室公寓，做着那种为十几岁女孩打耳洞的蹩脚工作，还有那一系列闻起来像没洗头、油腻腻的蹩脚男友，而Stephanie回到豪宅、律师事务所和那个厨艺堪比米其林厨师的热辣入赘丈夫身边？
My mansion! My law firm! My hot house-husband! It isn't fair. And I would be Rachel, she thought. I'm Rachel?
我的豪宅！我的律师事务所！我的热辣老公！这不公平。而且我会是Rachel，她想。我是Rachel？
"I've still got one wish," she said to the genie. "I didn't actually make my third wish back in the flat." The green man nodded. "Then finish her off," she said. "Rachel's body. Kill it. And leave me alone." She lit another menthol cigarette and walked away. Sometimes one wish is all you need.
“我还有一个愿望，”她对精灵说。“我在公寓时实际上并没有许下第三个愿望。”绿男人点了点头。“那就结束它，”她说。“Rachel的身体。干掉它。然后别来烦我。”她点燃了另一支薄荷烟走开了。有时候，一个愿望就足够了。
Marie Phillips, who is a younger sister, by the way, as am I. Marie's latest book is Create Your Own Midlife Crisis, the best way to make the worst decisions.
Marie Phillips，顺便提一下，她和我一样也是个妹妹。Marie的最新著作是《创造你自己的中年危机》，这是做出最烂决定的最好方式。
Act Three, One Pill Made Me Small. This past year, writer Karla Cornejo Villavicencio made a change that had the potential to alter who she has known herself to be for many years. She really didn't know who would emerge. A heads up, this story briefly mentions suicide. Here's Karla.
第三幕，一颗药丸让我变小。在过去的一年里，作家Karla Cornejo Villavicencio做出了一项可能会改变她多年来自我认知定义的决定。她真的不知道谁会因此显现出来。提示一下，这个故事简要提到了自杀。有请Karla。
In my early 20s, I would sometimes flirt with boys I didn't even like at parties I didn't want to be at by saying things like, "I'm on the maximum dose of my antipsychotic," because I liked that it made me sound dangerous, and it felt like a general disclaimer that nothing I said should be taken seriously. Now, if I say, "I went off my antipsychotic," with no suggestive inflection, with no inflection at all, at 33 years old, married to a woman, increasingly allergic to alcohol, this also makes me sound dangerous, but not in a socially-sanctioned hot way.
20岁出头时，我有时会在那些我根本不想去的派对上跟我不喜欢的男孩调情，我会说些诸如“我正在服用最大剂量的抗精神病药”之类的话，因为我喜欢那让我听起来很危险，而且这感觉像是一个免责声明，表示我所说的话都不应该被当真。现在，如果我说，“我停了我的抗精神病药，”没有暗示性的语调，没有任何语调，在33岁时，和一个女人结婚，对酒精越来越过敏，这也让我听起来很危险，但不是那种社会认可的酷炫方式。
You can't escape the stigma. It's there if you're on these pills. It's there if you go off the pills. This is a story of coming off the pills.
你无法逃避这种耻辱。如果你在吃药，它就在那儿。如果你停药，它也在那儿。这是一个关于停药的故事。
One night last fall, I told my partner, Talya, that something was off. I couldn't feel sadness or joy. I couldn't distinguish indignation and frustration from excitement. I thought it had to do with my current antipsychotic, Latuda.
去年秋天的一个晚上，我告诉我的伴侣Talya，有些不对劲。我感觉不到悲伤或快乐。我分不清愤慨和沮丧与兴奋。我以为这和我当时服用的抗精神病药物Latuda有关。
I have never experienced psychosis, but Latuda is prescribed for other things too. I'd been taking it for thoughts that go round and round and a general state of suicidal feeling. I struggled with sometimes explosive emotions that I had a hard time regulating.
我从未经历过精神病，但Latuda也被处方用于治疗其他问题。我一直在服用它，是因为那些转个不停的念头和一种普遍的自杀倾向。我有时会陷入难以调节的爆发性情绪中。
And in the years since the original prescription, thanks to lots and lots of therapy, I'd grown stronger and more stable. The Latuda had saved my life, but in the way that a sedating dart saves your life. It made me so lethargic that it was impossible to act out on all my feelings or even to feel them.
在最初服药后的几年里，多亏了大量的治疗，我变得更强大、更稳定了。Latuda曾经救过我的命，但就像麻醉枪救你的命那样。它让我如此昏昏欲睡，以至于不可能去把所有感受付诸行动，甚至无法去感知它们。
I asked my psychiatrist what he thought about maybe going off the Latuda. He said he was proud of the work I'd done over the past couple of years. It felt like a bespoke commencement speech. I cried. And then we made a plan to taper my dose down to zero.
我问我的精神科医生，对于尝试停掉Latuda他怎么看。他说他为我过去几年所做的努力感到骄傲。那感觉像是一场量身定制的毕业演讲。我哭了。然后我们制定了一个将剂量降到零的计划。
Just to be clear, I'm not anti-med. I love meds. I believe my antidepressants-- plural-- which I still take, are helping me thrive. But the Latuda was different. It's a heavy medication targeting challenges I had addressed in therapy. Maybe I was ready to try life without it.
声明一下，我不反药。我热爱药物。我相信我仍在服用的抗抑郁药——复数——正在帮我茁壮成长。但Latuda不同。这是一种针对我已经在治疗中解决过的挑战的强效药物。也许我准备好尝试没有它的生活了。
I'd been on one antipsychotic or another since my early 20s. I didn't know what I was like without this medication. It was an odd feeling to realize that I did not know who I was at baseline, as an adult. I could be anyone, and that was maybe the scariest thing about going off the Latuda. What if I was unrecognizable to Talya or my dog or my editors? What if I became unrecognizable to myself?
从20岁出头开始，我就一直在服用这样那样的抗精神病药。我不知道没有这种药我会是什么样。意识到作为成年人我不知道自己的基准状态是什么，这种感觉很奇怪。我可以是任何人，而这也许是停掉Latuda最可怕的地方。如果Talya或我的狗或我的编辑认不出我了怎么办？如果连我自己都认不出自己了怎么办？
I started tapering off Latuda in November. And in January, I taped a conversation with Talya about how it was going.
我从十一月开始减掉Latuda。在 январь，我录下了我和Talya关于进展如何的对话。
You and I have been together, like, six years. And this entire time, I've been on an antipsychotic. Most of the time. Most of the time. And so when I was thinking about going down on the Latuda or off of the Latuda, I was like, certainly, the person married to me right now likes the person that I am on the Latuda. And I wondered how you were going to react to somebody you didn't know or maybe you didn't like off the Latuda.
你和我在一起大概六年了。这期间我一直在服用抗精神病药。大部分时间都是。所以当我考虑减少或停掉Latuda时，我想，当然，现在嫁给我的人肯定喜欢服用Latuda时的我。我想知道当你面对一个你不了解或可能不喜欢、没服用Latuda的我时，你会作何反应。
You're asking if I was worried about that too?
你是问我也在为此担心吗？
No. How do you respond to what I said? Like, I'm prompting you to talk.
不。你对我刚才说的话有什么回应？比如，我在引导你说话。
Yeah.
是的。
See, I didn't ask you a yes-or-no question.
看，我没有问你一个是或否的问题。
I am formulating a thought as though on an academic panel.
我正在像在学术讨论会上那样构思一个想法。
Talya teaches college students and does her best to get me to write with outlines, thesis statements, and evidence to support my findings. Talya and I got together in grad school at Yale, and she often fact-checks my memories because those years are a blur. I was popping Ativan from mini Altoid tins in literature seminars and new sedating medications had me falling asleep in cafes, wandering lost in downtown New Haven.
Talya教大学生，并尽其所能让我用大纲、论点和证据来支持我的结论。Talya和我在耶鲁的研究生院认识，她经常核对我的记忆，因为那几年的生活是一片模糊。我在文学研讨会上把阿替万从薄荷糖盒里偷偷拿出来吃，新的镇静药物让我甚至在咖啡馆里睡着，在纽黑文市中心游荡迷路。
Over time, with a rotating door of psychiatrists, diagnoses, and medications, including Latuda, I got better in the ways we measure getting better for mental illness. I made plans with friends. I was productive. I wore lipstick. But a deep sadness gnawed away at me all the time. That scared me. It made me feel damaged and broken and radioactive in ways I couldn't even understand.
随着时间的推移，经过轮番的精神科医生、诊断和药物，包括Latuda，我在心理疾病康复的评估标准上变好了。我和朋友约会。我很有成效。我涂口红。但一种深深的悲伤时刻在啃噬着我。那让我害怕。它让我觉得自己支离破碎，仿佛带有某种我甚至无法理解的放射性。
OK, so it's been how many months since I stopped taking the Latuda? January, February, March, April, May-- five months.
好的，那么距离我停止服用Latuda已经过去几个月了？一月、二月、三月、四月、五月——五个月。
No way.
不会吧。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
That's almost half a year. How do you remember that it was January?
那都快半年了。你怎么记得是那一月停的？
I kept a diary. But yeah, those were some long evenings that I just spent in the bedroom kind of just lying down.
我有写日记。但确实，那些漫长的夜晚我只是躺在卧室里。
What do you remember about it? When you think about that time, do you remember a certain feeling?
你记得什么？当你想到那段时间，你记得某种感觉吗？
I remember maybe the first three months, I wanted to--
我记得可能前三个月，我想要——
Go back?
回去？
To go back, yeah.
是的，回去。
Yeah. Are you glad I discouraged it?
是的。你很高兴我阻止了你吗？
Well, maybe you should say why you discouraged it.
嗯，也许你应该说说为什么你阻止了我。
Yeah. Frequently, you would have bad days, and you would announce to me that you had decided that you needed Latuda. And I would say to you, OK, that's fine, and, before you make such a big decision, why don't you make sure that you're not reacting to withdrawal?
是的。你经常会有糟糕的日子，然后你会宣布你决定你需要Latuda。我会对你说，好的，没问题，但在做这么大的决定前，为什么不确保你不是在对戒断反应做出过度反应呢？
Yeah.
是的。
Just find out.
去弄清楚。
Yeah.
是的。
Because once you go back on, you're going to lose the opportunity to have that data. So I was like, if you could just wait. And it wasn't because I didn't want you to be on Latuda. It was honestly because I wanted you to know and think about what you know now.
因为一旦你重新开始服用，你就会失去获取那些数据的机会。所以我当时想，如果你能等一下。这并不是因为我不想让你服用Latuda。老实说是因为我想让你知道并思考你现在所知道的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
And you wouldn't have ever gotten the chance to know that.
而且你永远不会有机会知道那些。
No.
不。
What do you remember about wanting to go back on it and thinking you couldn't do it? What do you remember?
你记得关于想重新服药以及认为自己做不到的那部分，你记得什么？你记得什么？
I remember thinking that it was a lot of work, you know?
我记得当时觉得那是一项繁重的工作，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember just having a sense-- what I always wanted to know was the baseline.
我记得当时只有一种感觉——我一直想知道的是基准是什么。
Right.
没错。
Who I was, what I was at the baseline. And off the Latuda, I didn't really know, right, if what I was experiencing at that time was who I really was.
我是谁，基准状态下的我又是怎样的。而在停掉Latuda之后，我真的不知道，对吧，当时我经历的是不是真正的我。
Yeah.
是的。
But what I did know is that I was experiencing bodily things like the night sweats and the clamminess and these other things that made me feel like--
但我确实知道我正在经历身体上的反应，比如盗汗、潮湿，还有其他让我觉得……
Nausea, headache.
恶心、头痛。
Constant nausea, headaches, that made me feel like an old computer that's just running all the time, that just feels really, really hot.
持续的恶心、头痛，让我觉得自己像一台一直在运行的老电脑，感觉真的非常、非常热。
I feel like the thing that's-- so what happened when you went off the Latuda, right, there was this kind of eruption of emotion and agitation and frustration. And you got really scared, I think, that maybe your baseline was too much and you didn't want your baseline. Right? And then you kept hanging in there. You kept hanging in there.
我觉得发生的事情是——当你停掉Latuda后，发生了一种情绪、焦躁和挫败感的喷发。我想你当时真的被吓到了，认为也许你的基准状态太过强烈，你不想面对那样的基准。对吧？但你坚持住了。你一直在坚持。
I did keep hanging in there. For many months, I didn't know what was me and what was the withdrawal. But slowly, the bodily agitation, migraines, and shivers lifted, and I was left with me.
我确实一直在坚持。好几个月里，我不知道什么是真正的我，什么是戒断反应。但慢慢地，身体的焦躁、偏头痛和颤抖消退了，留下的就是我。
The difference between you on and off the Latuda is huge. It's absolutely huge. But it's not your fear of a different personality coming out. It's not like that at all.
你服用和不服用Latuda的区别是巨大的。绝对巨大。但这并不是因为你害怕某种不同的人格会显露出来。根本不是那样。
No, I don't seem to have a different personality.
不，我看起来并没有不同的人格。
It's true. I'm not a different person off the Latuda. But everything is harder now. Moving through my day is like trying to beat egg whites into a meringue without a mixer, just a butter knife-- all effort, and I'm bone tired at the end of each day.
这是真的。停掉Latuda后我并没有变成另一个人。但现在一切都更困难了。度过每一天就像试图不用搅拌机，只用一把黄油刀去把蛋白打发成蛋白霜——全是苦力，每天结束时我都累得骨头散架。
I feel much more sensitive than I have ever felt-- tender, sore, and scared-- like a prey animal, a baby deer, or a Yorkie with a bobcat for a neighbor. It takes almost nothing to make me fall apart-- not being able to open a jar, dropping a mug of coffee, taking the weather personally. I fall apart multiple times a day.
我觉得自己比以往任何时候都更敏感——柔弱、酸痛、恐惧——就像一只猎物，一只小鹿，或者一只把山猫当邻居的约克夏梗。几乎任何小事都能让我崩溃——打不开罐子、掉了一个马克杯、把天气太热归咎于自己。我每天崩溃好多次。
But it also takes almost no time to gather myself now. If I feel overwhelmed, I excuse myself to another room, set a 15-minute timer, blast the AC, and cry. I watch a video about chipmunk facts narrated by a young man who seems as delighted by chipmunks as I am. And then I'm fine.
但现在我也能很快地把自己重新拼凑起来。如果我觉得不知所措，我会借口去另一个房间，定个15分钟的闹钟，开到最大的空调，然后大哭一场。我看一个讲述花栗鼠事实的视频，解说是一个看起来和我一样为花栗鼠着迷的年轻人。然后我就没事了。
I'm back downstairs making coffee, scheduling doctor's appointments and Zoom meetings, sometimes even before the alarm goes off. Latuda, which was supposed to protect me from emotional intensity, which was supposed to prevent me from breaking down, just kept me stuck in bed, sad about being sad.
我又下楼去煮咖啡，安排医生的预约和Zoom会议，有时甚至在闹钟响之前就开始了。Latuda本应保护我免受强烈情绪的影响，本应防止我崩溃，结果却让我困在床上，为悲伤而悲伤。
I've also noticed that I can concentrate better now for longer stretches of time. For a while on Latuda, I could not read, not at all. I could only reread, and that felt lonely. I'm reading again.
我还注意到我现在能更长时间地集中注意力了。服用Latuda的那段时间，我根本无法阅读，一点也不能。我只能重读，这感觉很孤独。我又开始阅读了。
One morning, I took my dog and demons on a walk in the nearby woods. I was midway through the first chapter of Edith Wharton's House of Mirth on audiobook. I was kind of star-struck, starry-eyed about the rhythm of her sentences, the wickedness and speed of her wit, and the sensuous appreciation of melodrama. I felt a bit like a teenybopper. I felt about Wharton the way I felt about John Mayer in seventh grade and Room for Squares came out, and on it, the song, "Your Body is a Wonderland."
一天早上，我带着狗和恶魔在附近的树林里散步。我正听着伊迪丝·华顿的《欢乐之家》有声书的第一章。我简直像是被震慑住了，被她句子的节奏、她机智的邪恶与速度，以及对通俗剧感官上的欣赏迷住了。我感觉自己像个狂热的追星族。我对华顿的感觉就像我七年级时对约翰·梅尔的感觉，当《Room for Squares》发行时，里面有首歌叫《Your Body is a Wonderland》。
I'm confronting strangers again. That's back. Maybe it's because I grew up in New York under Giuliani or because my dad had an explosive temper and, once my brother was born, I learned that if I was scared someone with more power was going to be a fucking asshole to someone with less power, I could put my body in between them and dare the bully to blink first. The thing about me is I never blink first.
我又开始直面陌生人了。那个特质又回来了。也许是因为我在朱利安尼治理下的纽约长大，或者因为我爸爸脾气暴躁，而且我弟弟出生后，我意识到如果我害怕某个更有权力的人会欺负一个弱者，我可以把身体挡在他们中间，敢让那个恶霸先眨眼。关于我的事就是，我从不先眨眼。
A couple of months ago, I ran a guy out of a liquor store downtown because he did a little bow and said namaste to an Indian kid who was working behind the counter. He also kept interrogating him about the village where he was born, and the kid clearly did not want to talk about it. He looked pained and annoyed.
几个月前，我把一个家伙赶出了市中心的一家酒类商店，因为他对着柜台后工作的印度男孩鞠了一躬，说了句“纳马斯特”（namaste）。他还一直审问那个男孩关于他出生的村庄，而那个男孩显然不想谈这个。他看起来痛苦又恼火。
When I was being rung up, I aggressively scrolled through Instagram, trying to distract myself. The cashier said something to me. I did not hear it and asked him to repeat himself. Then I heard myself say, "I'm sorry. Can you say that again? I was distracted by how much that guy knows about India."
当我结账时，我愤怒地刷着Instagram，试图分散自己的注意力。收银员对我说了些什么。我没听清，让他再说一遍。然后我听到自己说，“抱歉。你能再说一遍吗？我被那个家伙对印度的了解程度分散了注意力。”
The guy and his wife heard me say that too and announced this store did not have the wine they were looking for after all. That's when the guy did a little bow and said namaste to the cashier. "Sir, that's fucking rude," I told him. They left the store. I wouldn't have done that on the Latuda. Maybe I wouldn't do it again. But it certainly sounds like me.
那个家伙和他的妻子也听到了我的话，宣布这家店根本没有他们要买的酒。就在那时，那家伙又鞠了一躬，对收银员说了句“纳马斯特”。“先生，你真没礼貌，”我告诉他。他们离开了商店。要是吃着Latuda，我绝对不会那样做。也许我不会再那么做。但那听起来确实是我。
I remember the exact moment a few months ago-- in the middle of the night, on the toilet-- when I realized I felt happy. Nothing had happened. I was still half-asleep. But the rush was unmistakable. I grabbed my phone and made note of the time-- 2:00 AM-- and wrote a short description of what that felt like in case I wouldn't remember it, in case I needed photographic proof of the Loch Ness monster in the morning.
我记得几个月前确切的那一刻——在深夜，在洗手间里——我意识到我感到快乐。什么事也没发生。我还有点迷糊。但那股冲击是无可置疑的。我抓起手机记下了时间——凌晨2点——并写下了那种感觉的简短描述，以防我记不住，以防我早上需要尼斯湖水怪的照片证据。
Earlier this summer, I sat in the kiddie pool we picked up from Walmart with my book and my music and my dog. I'd been doing this every day for weeks, and it made me feel safe, lit from within with love for the whole world. I again wrote down the time and place.
今年夏天早些时候，我坐在我们从沃尔玛买来的小戏水池里，带着书、音乐和狗。我连续几周每天都这么做，这让我感到安全，内心闪烁着对整个世界的爱。我又记下了时间和地点。
At 12:07 PM from the hammock, my thighs and stomach covered by old wet hand towels we kept in the freezer to help regulate my body temperature, I emailed Talya only this, "I happy. Posterity pic of my yard day?" This must be what happy women feel, I think.
中午12点07分，我在吊床上，大腿和肚子盖着我们放在冰箱里用来调节体温的旧湿毛巾，我只给Talya发了一封邮件，“我快乐。庭院一天的纪念照？”我想，这就是快乐女人的感觉吧。
I also know that in a few hours, when the sun goes down, I will crash. Something about the color of the sky at dusk makes me feel gloomy and dark. It is irrational, and it is also very real. And when that happens, I won't remember what it felt like to be happy. So now I make a point to remember.
我也知道，几个小时后，当太阳下山时，我会崩溃。黄昏时天空的颜色总是让我感到阴郁和黑暗。这不合逻辑，但也非常真实。而当这种情况发生时，我就不会记得快乐是什么感觉了。所以我现在特意去记住它。
Something else I realized-- sadness comes back every day. It was there on the Latuda. It's there off the Latuda. The sadness is always in a corner. It goes where I go, like a shadow or a Disney sidekick. I hate it, but I think it's mine. It's like accepting, in the sixth grade, this is as tall as you're going to get.
我还意识到另一件事——悲伤每天都会回来。服用Latuda时它就在。停药后它也在。悲伤总是蜷缩在角落里。它如影随形，就像影子或迪士尼里的丑角。我讨厌它，但我认为它是属于我的。这就像在六年级时接受事实：这就是你能长到的最高高度了。
And then I realized that. And I told my psychiatrist. I was like, I think I'm probably going to always be sad. Remember? I was like, because that is a constant. And I think my entire life, I've been looking for an answer of like, just why am I so sad?
然后我意识到了。我告诉了我的精神科医生。我说，我觉得我可能永远都会悲伤。记得吗？我说，因为那是一个常数。我觉得我的一生都在寻找一个答案，就是为什么我这么悲伤？
And he was like, what if you just accept that that is how you're going to feel for the rest of your life? What decisions can you make for yourself to make life gentler and to do things that you want to do and to-- you know, like happiness or, I mean, non-sadness, he said that that wasn't the goal, that you could have a meaningful life, or you can have a fulfilling life, or you can have an influential life, and you didn't necessarily have to have a happy life.
他说，如果你只是接受这就是你余生会有的感觉呢？你可以为你自己做些什么决定来让生活更温柔，去做你想做的事情，以及——你知道，比如快乐，或者，我的意思是，不悲伤，他说那不是目标，你可以有一个有意义的生活，或者你可以有一个充实的生活，或者你可以有一个有影响力的生活，而不一定非要有一个快乐的生活。
And that was maybe like two months ago that he said that. And I think that was a turning point for me because I think the thing that I was always trying to correct in myself and find language for is I feel like there's a hole in my heart, like someone took a melon baller-- you know the melon ballers that you take? It's like an ice cream scooper.
那大概是两个月前他说的话。我认为那对我来说是一个转折点，因为我觉得我一直在试图纠正自己并寻找语言表达的是，我觉得我的心脏里有个洞，就像有人用挖球器——你知道那种挖球器吗？就像冰淇淋勺。
No, I know them. Yeah, I know those.
不，我知道它们。是的，我知道那些。
OK. So I feel like there's a melon-- OK, this is-- you know. But yeah--
好的。所以我感觉有个挖球器——好的，这是——你知道。但是的——
Yeah, yeah. You feel-- yeah.
是的，是的。你感觉——是的。
Now I'm just like, I guess that's the way it is.
现在我只是想，我想就是这样了。
Yeah. Everybody's different.
是的。每个人都是不同的。
Fortunately or unfortunately, it's still me I come home to every day, and I'm still learning who I am and what I'm like. But I am more curious about the too loud, too bright, too harsh world, ever and ever more curious with 30% less abject terror. I'm not sure I like myself yet, but I do trust myself to go on this journey, even if I end up in the back yard again, staring at a molting cardinal who is so freaky looking, I take a picture of it and then cry.
幸运还是不幸，每天回到家面对的仍然是我自己，我仍在学习我是谁以及我是什么样的人。但我对这个太吵、太亮、太残酷的世界越来越好奇，并且带着少了30%彻底恐惧的好奇心。我不确定我是否喜欢现在的自己，但我确实相信自己能走上这段旅程，即使最后我又回到了后院，盯着一只正在换毛的红雀，它看起来太怪异了，我给它拍了张照片然后大哭起来。
Karla Cornejo Villavicencio is the author of the book, The Undocumented Americans. Her story for us was produced by Susan Burton.
Karla Cornejo Villavicencio是《无证美国人》一书的作者。她为我们讲述的故事由Susan Burton制作。
Today's show was produced by me, Bim Adewunmi, and edited by David Kestenbaum. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Valerie Kipnis, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Tuck Woodstock and Rob Dubbin.
今天的节目由我Bim Adewunmi制作，David Kestenbaum编辑。参与今天节目制作的同事包括Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Valerie Kipnis, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, 以及Diane Wu。我们的总编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。特别感谢Tuck Woodstock和Rob Dubbin。
Sandy Allen is the author of the book, A Kind of Miraculous Paradise. My friend Mona Chalabi, who you heard talking about the weird feelings her house gave her, is actually working on a book about our feelings about money. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
Sandy Allen是《一种奇迹般的天堂》一书的作者。你刚才听到谈论房子带给她怪异感觉的朋友Mona Chalabi，其实正在写一本关于我们对金钱感受的书。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们700多集的节目存档。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给各公共电台。
Special thanks to our boss, Ira Glass. He was on Sesame Street the other week, and Cookie Monster for once wanted to share a treat. He was like-- (IMITATING COOKIE MONSTER) Ira, do you want cookie?
特别感谢我们的老板Ira Glass。他上周去了《芝麻街》，饼干怪兽破天荒地想分享一点好东西。他说——（模仿饼干怪兽的声音）Ira，你要吃饼干吗？
How could you ask me that, you monster?
你怎么能问我那个问题，你这个怪物？
I'm Bim Adewunmi. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Bim Adewunmi。Ira Glass下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。